هناك مظاهرات خرجت الان وهذه المظاهرات
جميعها تطالب بعدم التقارب من مع النظام
وترفض المصالحه مع النظام ستدعى الكاميرا
تظهر هذا الحشد الكبير الذي خرج هذا اليوم
في مدينه الباب
المطالبه همم رفع المتظاهرون خلال هذه
المظاهره شعارات طالبت باسقاط النظام كما
همم طالب المتظاهرون هنا بالافراج عن
المعتقلين ورفض المتظاهرون هنا من خلال
شعاراتهم اي تقارب مع نظام الاسد وهذا هو
الاسبوع الثاني الذي تخرج فيه هذه
المظاهرات ويقول المتظاهرون هنا بانه لا
يمكن التوصل الى اي حل بعد رحيل ال همم
النظام الاسد
ان هناك همم مطالب كثيره لم تحقق
للمتظاهرين من بينها الافراج عن المعتقلين
و و ايضا هناك همم يعني مطالب اخرى يطالب
بها المتظاهرون وما زال
الوفود تتوافد الى هذه المظاهره وهذا هو
مثال كثير من المظاهرات التي خرجت في عدد
من المدن والبلدات في ريف حلب